>> Hi, YouTube.
This is Traq Krim.
I'm the founder of NetVibes and now new CEO
of new company called
Jolicloud and I'm -- I'm pretty excited about
the Obama presidency.
I think there's lots to be told about the
way he won and the way he
actually puts, I believe are the most important
things in it and the
ecology at the top of the agenda in his administration.
And in a way I just hope that Europe will
be able to have the same kind
of -- Europe and the rest of the world is
kind of direction.
So I think the -- Obama is the president of
United States so he's
really gonna focus on this country but I believe
that it's the old
world is looking for some kind of calm-down
period of time.
Now we need to move focus on things without
more moral and allow that
are really targeted to help the people along
the world and I think that
part of what he's going to do will definitely
help the world going
further and obviously there's lots of hope
in U.S. There's a lot of
hope in the-- in the -- in the rest of the
world.
He's not a musician meaning that he won't
be able to fix everything but
I think that if you set the standard far very
high, there's an
opportunity for doing quite amazing things
and I'm pretty confident
he'll do it.